look first of all for those of you who
don't understand how the business works
of
internet traffic people have to click on
something
in order to advance the interest of the
business
and every headline is bait i think the
pejorative sense of click bait is when
someone gives you a headline
and the story doesn't back it up and
we've seen ads like that all the time
very and it's obvious in the that it is
bait
that they're that they're they're
they're deliberately
misstating in the headline what you're
gonna get
when you click on it and we try to never
do that and i always try to be on the
lookout for it i'm not gonna name names
here but i was seeing headlines over the
weekend
that matt lafleur has told jordan love
to prepare as if he's the starter
okay yeah that's wrong yes that's that's
true
but the broader context is this and
here's what he said to reporters last
week it's
the same message it's been all the time
you're only one play away so you always
have to prepare
like you're the starter yes you're the
backup prepare like you're the starter
not prepare like you're the starter
because aaron's not coming
prepare like you're the starter because
you're the number two
and and frankly chris and here's here's
why i bring this up
they asked lefleur and it's kind of a
naive question like why do you have so
many quarterbacks if jordan love got all
the reps with the first team well you do
individual drills you got a bunch of
guys you're throwing passes to
you need arms there to throw so they got
four quarterbacks
at otas or hat it's over now and they
got aaron rodgers they got five on the
roster and at one point
here's what leflore said here it is as
we get closer to training camp
and you know things could become a
little bit more clear for us
you know we potentially could make an
adjustment there
as it relates to the other quarterbacks
that was the moment i thought he knows
he knows aaron rodgers is going to be
there aaron rodgers how can you not let
your head coach know what you're
planning to do right your coach has
reason to know
i think rogers will let him know he's
going to be there and i think lafleur is
already thinking which of these guys
blake bortles jake dolagala which of
these guys are going to be told
hit the road jack because daddy's coming
home
and leflore knows it that's what i
believe that's right you know who your
daddy is it's aaron rodgers i like that
but no you're right i mean
they got they signed quarterbacks
because of what you're talking about
you know one arms two you know more
options to figure out if aaron rodgers
doesn't come back what gives us our best
you know
three quarterbacks in a room whatever
they want to give themselves that
availability that way but i'm with you
mike and the fact that
first off like we've been saying from
the get-go there is no
issue between aaron rodgers and the
coaches so
the coaches i would believe and matt
lafleur and rogers from anybody you talk
to seem like they have a really good
relationship it's very open
i would agree with you that he's a he's
let lefleur know
that like yeah i'm gonna be there blah
blah blah he probably even told him
i'm gonna continue to give the front
office and stuff hard time he probably
has lefour probably knows that who knows
if the relationship's good enough he
does you know and lefour
he he understands he's probably like
yeah i mean i get it go ahead give him a
hard time i don't know it's not between
me and you
or you know he's not getting in the
middle of it but i i would think that
the coaches
have an inkling you know about what
rogers is doing when i was gonna show up
whatever
and yes whether it's lefleur and nate
hackett
or whether he's talked to nate hackett
somebody knows there
and rogers is is keeping in contact and
yeah i mean
things are going to clear up as lefleur
says and the picture will get a little
more clear
when roger's daddy aka walks into camp
and it's one of those things that i
think should have been obvious to us all
along and you know
maybe i should have thought of it sooner
but it was in that moment when i
heard leflore explaining the reasoning
for having the quarterbacks and he made
that comment
as we get closer to camp and we get some
clarity he
he knows and yeah why wouldn't you tell
him if you're the head coach he's like
hey aaron look i don't
th that's not between you and me that's
between you and them
i just need to know you're right do i
need to get jordan love ready yeah right
really ready not just not just in in the
event that you break
collarbone again but but are you going
to be i need to know if you're going to
be here i won't tell anybody
your secret's safe with me i just need
to know and i feel like in that moment
there was an unintended glimpse
that that he's not freaked out about it
because i'd be wouldn't you be freaked
out about it
if you're the head coach of a team
that's gone 13-3 for two straight years
and you're six weeks away from training
camp and you're embarking on the only
period of time
during the year where life is sane and
manageable
you're going to spend every minute
wondering is my franchise quarterback
the reigning league mvp going to be
there or not
i think the least aaron rodgers could do
is let his head coach know and
uh i suspect i'd be stunned if he hasn't
i i would too i
i you know listen i i think lafleur's
been freaked out since the draft two
years ago going what the hell
what am i got involved in what am i in
the middle of here and
how do i handle this situation so you
know i think he understands the business
aspect of it what's going on
how it hurt rogers everything like that
and i'm i'm with you
i would think there's some line of
communication that he at least feels
pretty comfortable with and knows where
this is going at the end of the day and
maybe he knows something from the
organizational standpoint too that maybe
they're going to make some
effort finally to pay him more money i
don't see that happening but
i'm just throwing that out there but
either way i think he knows something we
don't that's for sure
i don't think the organization's going
to there's going to be many i think top
of the organization he doesn't want him
to come back
i think mark murphy doesn't want him to
come back and i think he's got no other
alternative what's he going to do he's
going to write a check for 11 and a half
million no no way he's going to give up
the six and
6.8 million dollar roster bonus he
earned earlier this year that gets paid
out
over the course of the season he's got a
14.7 million salary on top
it's a lot of money to give up and
you're giving up
one more shot at your personal legacy
yeah maybe that's right that's the
biggest thing you're going to give up 25
of it to make a point to mark murphy and
brian good koontz i don't think so
uh one last point on this i don't know
if you saw this over the weekend but
aaron rodgers has
paid for his green bay
country club membership through the end
of the year and look
how much how much can it be that's my
reaction it'd be great to say oh that
shows he's coming back or maybe he's
just trolling
mark murphy by doing it how much can it
be
this is you know like when i remember
when i was a kid my dad would sit on the
couch and he always wore
slacks and the pockets of those slacks
were very conducive to coins rolling out
so he'd sit in the couch and
coins would roll out and from my
perspective hey baby it's fair game it's
buried treasure
i mean whatever it costs for aaron
rodgers
to extend his membership at the green
bay country club through the end of the
season
is less to him than whatever
quarters and dimes rolled out of dad's
pockets
into the couch it's nothing it's peanuts
it's far less meaningful than the 10
grand that randy moss had to pay
for rubbing his butt against the
goalpost so i don't think it means a
damn thing no
it means nothing rogers is smart enough
too to maybe know to like
renew that to to make public perception
kind of just quiet down
about the whole issue who knows he might
not even know in general
i mean he might have people like aaron
rodgers
nothing intentional about it right you
don't think so he
has an assistant where they got
something that said hey you got to pay
this to roll over your membership and
keep going and they just
paid it like you're right like you don't
even think about it like what rogers
needs a new coca-cola
oh he needs a new membership great
that's what's the same thing to them it
means nothing
so i'm with you you're right i'm not
reading too deep into that at all
he he probably would get upset if his
time in hawaii or wherever it is
was interrupted even for five seconds
when they asked him
do you want us to pay out whatever the
dues are whatever the fees are i mean
what can they be i'm in no country clubs
uh but i don't think about all that
expensive grand scheme of things
especially if you're making
20 what 35 million a year i have a
feeling it's not that much
in comparison to what your your income
is uh and i
i wouldn't think it is for his income
especially uh
yeah and i don't think it's anything
that's yeah affecting him either way i
don't belong to a country club either
i'm not a golfer that way
so i wouldn't be able to i'm surprised
you don't i'm just surprised
oh yeah you are huh don't just because
it's a status thing
you know and and you had that very
coddled and cushy
upbringing in in
yeah live in greenwich i'm just
surprised right you know
i wonder how many people just are in a
country club just so they can
say they're in a country club even if
they never go to the country club i
thought that's what a lot of it was
yeah no not for me sorry this is
nitty-gritty tough stuff over here okay
you know we i don't mess with that
country club stuff over here i just
no i don't mess with it i'll be i'll be
because you're a vampire i don't know
why
why no where i grew up
where i grew up they didn't want the
italians in the country clubs oh
sure your country club that's my
attitude my entire life oh i hear that
hey fine i'll join in on that you want
to do it together i'll do it too
yeah okay hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports